Sometimes basic arithmetic isn't enough to solve a problem and you need to use
one of the many math functions that Java has to offer. In fact, there's so many
that you couldn't possibly remember them all, and we prepared a fact sheet for
you. Let me just go over the most important one. Let's say you need to compute
a power such as 2 to the 10th. You can't write that exponent neatly in Java,
instead you use a function and the syntax looks like this. The function name is
pow, it's in a class called Math. You have to reference it as Math.pow. Then,
you give it to the two operands, the 2 goes here, and the 10 becomes the second
one. If you need to compute the square root, you use the square root function.
Again, it's in the Math class, Math.sqrt, and whatever it goes inside the root
symbol in Math notation goes inside the parentheses here. For absolute values,
there is another function. It's called abs and whatever you put between the
vertical bars in Math notation goes on inside here. Now, these kinds of
functions come up often enough that I want you to practice this a little bit.
Here, I have a bunch of function calls, and I'd just like you to tell me for
each of them, what is the result? If you like, you can compute it in BlueJ, or
you can just do it in your head.